- I'm the baddest (beep)
on this whole prison here bitch.
Yeah, you heard?
Check it out, let's go.
I'm the baddest dude.
(screaming loudly)
(tense music)
(alarm blaring)
- [Narrator] Lewis Lawrence is
beginning his life sentence.
(tense music)
In order to survive,
he must join a gang.
- Do you understand?
I know how it worked, right?
When you in prison, what you
need is protection rights,
and the way to do that,
is by getting into a gang.
(tense music)
I was surprised to find out
that there is a
bald gang in prison.
They gonna be my homies.
Talking about some BBWW,
Bald Brothers What What?
What's up homie?
Nice haircut.
- Get the (beep) outta here.
- I mean, they haven't
officially asked me
to be in the gang yet,
'cause you need to earn
their respect first.
- Hey.
You're in the
wrong neighborhood,
black mother (beep)
(tense music)
(Lewis screaming)
- Step off my homies
mother (beep),
or I'll (beep) up.
Bald brotherhood y'all.
Yeah, bald
brotherhood, what's up?
What's up, you know
what I'm talking about.
But that was it
right there, okay?
That's what they call a jump in.
That's the initiation process.
So it's my understanding,
that I am now a member of the
bald brotherhood gang, okay?
I mean, those mother (beep)
beat the (beep) outta me.
That's a euphemism
you hear all the time.
But you don't know if it's
true, it can't be true,
how's it possible?
But that mother
(beep) went blip!
And diarrhea just went
(rumbles) right out my ass.
So I hope,
like I hope that's like
lifetime dudes right there.
It's the happiest day of
my life is what I'm saying.
- [Narrator] Despite the
lack of encouragement,
Lewis continues to try and
ingratiate himself to the gang.
- What?
This long haired bitch.
Yeah, that's what I'm
talking about hairo.
Trying to creep up my
bald brothers bitch.
Ought to kick you again.
- Hey, you all right
man? You all right?
Come on, get up, get up.
We got you son, we got you son.
- Get your hands off me you
hair having mother (beep)
I mean, I think I
accidentally got hit
by some of my bald brothers.
(alarm blaring)
That's right, bald
brotherhood forever man.
What's up.
But you know, that's prison man.
I mean, you don't never know
what side it's coming from.
- [Narrator] Lewis has
yet to make any alliances.
Meanwhile, an
unprecedented piece
has been broken between
black and white prison gangs.
The one since a
mountable racial divide,
now bridged by a mutual hatred,
for Lewis.
- Hey man,
you gotta let me outta here.
- Oh, okay.
(tense upbeat music)
(keys jingling)
You tricked me.
- I can honestly say, I
wasn't trying to trick you.
- You weren't?
- All I said was, you
gotta let me outta here,
there's no trick.
- So I do have to
let you outta here?
- Yes.
- Okay.
(tense upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
Orders to let him go,
I don't know why he is in
there in the first place,
I don't know.
Like you really
got me in trouble.
- Sorry.
- Yeah, you must
think I'm stupid
well, I'm not stupid, I'm smart.
So, yeah.
- You know how you can prove
that you're really smart?
- Oh yeah, let me guess,
you want me to let
you outta here again.
- Well.
- You know what, you
think you can trick me
into letting you out
again, well you can't,
because this is my choice.
Get the heck outta here.
- All right.
Reverse psychology.
I am sorry about that guys.
That was me guys,
my bad, my bad.
Real nice.
Now they said they're
gonna dock my pay
and if I let you
outta here again,
then I'm gonna be
severely punished.
(Officer mumbles)
- I'm actually surprised they
haven't already thrown you
in here with me.
- No, prison is for bad guys.
You're a bad guy,
and I'm a good guy.
- Yeah, but you can see
how from my perspective,
I'm a good guy.
- Wait, you are a good guy?
Oh my gosh.
- It doesn't seem like you
understand what your job is.
- Oh, oh, okay.
I see what you're doing.
You're trying to manipulate
me with reverse psychology.
Well, it's not gonna work.
- It's not even worth
going out there again.
Look, they're just gonna get
me, and bring me back in here,
just like they always do.
Unless--
- What?
- No,
forget it, I don't wanna take
advantage of you anymore.
- Look, look, hey
look, no, no, listen,
I'm not gonna fall for it.
Whatever it is, you may
as well just tell me.
- I was just gonna say that,
if you were to help me,
- Uh huh.
- Get past the guards--
- Yeah, yeah.
- Get all the way out.
I really, no, I
have to tell you.
You need to think about
this, long and hard.
Weigh your options,
and consider the ramifications
of those options.
- Like heck I will.
Let's go.
I'm busting you outta here.
- Don't yell man, you might
as well ring the alarm man.
- Good idea, yeah.
(alarms ringing)
- Hi Tom.
Good to see you guys.
Oh boy, I did it
again, didn't I?
I was in prison.
A guard, I was a prison guard.
I wasn't allowed to
talk to the prisoners.
That was the thing,
they said to me,
if you talk to those prisoners,
you're gonna get in trouble.
You're gonna get in trouble.
(foreboding music)
- Yo man, you okay in here?
'Cause everyone on the
outside know you didn't talk.
We got mad respect for you dawg.
Right mad respect.
- Yes, and I am still
happy with that decision.
- The first time
I was in lockup,
dawg, I was scared shitless man.
- Scared shitless.
Yes, that is an accurate
way to describe it.
- Yeah man, but you know,
wasn't too long before I
made this place my bitch.
- Oh, there's plenty
of that going on.
- Yo, I ran this place man.
Man, you must be
running this (beep).
- Well, I am doing
quite a bit of running.
- And you know, there's a
certain pecking order in prison.
You know, you got the
brothers on the top,
and you got the
brothers on the bottom.
You understand?
- Yes.
I understand that very
clearly, and very frequently.
- That's my dawg.
Now, the reason I came though,
is we got kind of a problem.
You know a crazy brother in here
go by the name of Seven Inch?
- Yes.
I definitely know Seven Inch.
- All right well, Seven Inch run
with the Willis
brothers, all right?
And he knows some (beep)
Well, let's just say we can't
have this guy naming names.
All right?
We thought since
you on the inside,
you could take care of it.
You know what I'm talking about?
- You want me to take
care of Seven Inch?
- Yeah, you know, just
take him out the equation.
The problem is,
getting time with him.
- No, I can get time with him.
Oh yes,
I do believe I will most likely
be seeing him this evening.
- That's awesome.
But you gotta get
him alone though.
- Though,
that won't be a problem.
- Okay.
Well, what's your plan
man, how you gonna do it?
- What do you say I,
bite his (beep) off.
- Excuse me?
- Just bring my teeth
down hard on his (beep)
- Dawg, how you
gon' get that close?
- Way ahead of you on that one.
(laughing)
- Oh man.
You bad man.
That's some hard (beep) dawg.
This place ain't
changed you man.
- You have no idea.
(door buzzing)
- Lil Wayne y'all.
The Carter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm coming to y'all straight
from Rikers Penitentiary bitch.
You heard man.
Hey man.
Haters out there
think I'm playing.
Think I'm some kind of joke man.
Yeah, young money.
Check this out right here man.
I'm the baddest mother (beep)
on this whole prison here bitch.
Yeah, you heard, check it out.
Let's go.
I'm the baddest dude.
(screaming)
Lil Wayne y'all.
Young Money.
Y'all need to watch
your back you heard?
That's right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause I'm coming for y'all.
You know, what's up man?
I run this.
In fact y'all let's go.
I'm the baddest.
Where you going man?
Where you going?
Hey man, where you going?
You ain't gotta go.
(taser buzzing)
(screaming)
Okay, I see pick on
the little guy, huh?
Punks.
(screaming)
This little ironic
mother (beep) right here.
(upbeat music)
I don't think we should
be doing this right.
Young money.
You know what I mean,
there's a time and a place.
Man, I ain't scared.
(upbeat pop music)
(water trickling)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh I want you ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪